make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with Secret
Wars 1984 we are in the the conclusion
we are at the end of this story and it's
been fun right it's been fun covering
Secret Wars
I really enjoyed covering this story
because Secret Wars I think it's pretty
solid in this point like we immediately
pick up the Doctor Doom with the power
of the Beyonder and it's kind of funny
because as soon as he sort of manifests
right as soon as he shows up to the
heroes like he did at the end of the
last comic basically what he throws out
or throws out here is the beyonders dead
and and all the power that he had now
belongs to me I could destroy all of you
with a single thought which is probably
what you expect me to do and it's like
okay why would you open up with that
phrase though why would you open up with
that statement and here's here's the
funny thing about this right this is
this is what's so interesting about this
the heroes are debating whether or not
they should attack for all the good that
this would do it would be like if you
like ants launching an attack against
Galactus it's just kind of funny right
like what what hope could these heroes
possibly have against the various
villains who are here right now one of
the big things that kind of takes place
simultaneously where the heroes are sort
of debating what to do with with Doctor
Doom is you have the molecule man Owen
Reese now this is one of the most
important parts of the story right
because this sets the stage for Owen
going forward not just in the immediate
aftermath of Secret Wars right because
some of the things that we're done here
were eliminated almost right off the bat
right either they were eliminated in in
in really short order or they took a
little bit of time but they basically
came to an end right not a whole lot of
things that came out of lasted the long
term and are like still going on in
Marvel Comics but what the molecule man
it definitely is a release it was until
Secret Wars three the unofficial secret
war story from Fantastic Four but the
way this plays out is that the molecule
man like a lot of the other villains
believe that Doctor Doom is basically
betraying them right now the truth and
what they always kind of knew was that
this was really doctor dooms plan right
the plan of doom was to steal the power
of the Beyonder it was always that way
or at least to kill the Beyonder and
take its power according to do that was
the plan in which he had always been
intending to implement he just now got
around to it but the funny thing is what
isn't happening as a molecule man uses
his powers to basically shift the heroes
away right so it literally take this
chunk of rocket death Iran and shift him
away to a different location and then
immediately goes to attack Doctor Doom
and as soon as that happens like the
molecule man's like I didn't rule
anything that's not a living molecule so
like your suit of armor different things
like that and so because that dooms like
you're a lot more powerful than you
think let me show you and what he does
is immediately
lab Owen Reese and what he what he
reveals to him and again this is a
hugely important thing what he reveals
is that the molecule man has the ability
to manipulate all molecules there's no
limit right living molecules molecules
that are not living there there's no
difference there he can manipulate them
all now again it's not molecules is
essentially subatomic matter is what the
what the molecule man is controlling but
again you know subatomic man does it
really sound it didn't really roll off
the tongue the same way molecule man
does but nonetheless basically what he
tells Owen Reese is that your limits on
your power are not due to the nature of
your power right your power doesn't have
any actual limits you can control
everything throughout the entirety of
the universe and even the multiverse if
you chose to write like your power
transcends pretty much every other
source of power out there with the
exception of mine now this is an
important thing because this does
include Galactus right Owen Reese is
more powerful than Galactus doom
basically says the limits on your power
or because you're afraid you have this
self-hate you have this fear of your
powers let's strip all that away and
basically removes these subconscious
mental blocks that Owen Reese had in his
one and when that happens
Owen Reese's powers basically amplify
right so it's like when Gohan with
mystic for the first time basically like
he's just sitting with like like old man
Chi like old Chi and then Gohan freaks
out flares up and his power is just like
insane so that's kind of what's going on
here the mental blocks of Owen Reese
have been removed there are now no
limits to Owens power and this comes to
fruition when he literally manifests a
kind of yacht of sorts out of nowhere
and then they just go flying back to a
base of operations and so what they end
up doing or at least what Owen does is
he sends them all the way back to Denver
Colorado and I remember Denver is one of
the many places that have basically been
collected into battleworld right so
these people are here with no earthly
clue how it was that they got here but
of course they end up going to the
apartment of Marsha
and it's kind of this funny moment right
because there's one point where Marsha
is talking to Owen and he's like well
you know we gotta get out of here now
she's like we can go back to my place
and it's just kind of like okay alright
Marsha I see what you're doing but
nonetheless it's it's kind of cool right
because when this goes down they kind of
start having these conversations and
they're like we're already back in
Denver Colorado just send us home just
like send us back to our residence
because in reality with the beyonders
power having been taken by by dr. doom
the contest is essentially over the
force field that was there was basically
keeping them out of keeping them from
from that or leaving battleworld
is essentially gone now right they can
leave anytime they want
but the biggest issue here is now you
have dr. doom with godly power right dr.
doom has become God how what do you do
about that right what's dr. doom going
to do with that power that's the concern
here and so what you start to see is
Owen Reese basically create this kind of
bubble by manipulating subatomic matter
create this bubble over Denver and then
just like yank it out of a ttle world
and basically start sitting it on its
way that's what they say kind of nuts
because from there you basically shift
over to the Incredible Hulk and Colossus
now for Colossus it's weird man right
Chris Colossus has this great big huge
thing like this this huge love interest
going on with like za z he's known this
girl for like four days right so with
Kitty Pryde he's known that girl for
years right him is they've been they've
been maybe not years but like for a long
time right he's like yeah man this girl
like she's my girlfriend like we've
known each other for a really long time
but like I just met this chick though
and I've known her for like three days
so like I'm in love now and it's like
okay Colossus so basically you've never
been with a girl before is what
everybody's kind of assuming here
because it's really what it looks like
right this guy's brand-new to the world
but for the Incredible Hulk he basically
is kind of lying you know sort of just
laying there kind of collecting himself
and it suddenly hit by a blast of energy
and when that happens he kind of just
starts lumbering along and an almost
sleepwalking comatose state now of
course Julia carpenter tries to jump in
eventually slow him down it's gonna be
like you know I don't know where this
guy's going but we got to keep him
contained and then the energy basically
passes from the Incredible Hulk
into India Julia carpenter and then she
goes all the way back to or goes to
where where Ulysses Klaw is and then
seems to go there for the purpose of
either grabbing him or something along
those lines and then a giant like kind
of emits out of nowhere which seems to
snap her out of it right and so at that
point we end up finding out the dr. doom
that kind of visited the location he'd
basically reconstituted ulysses klaw and
then restored Monica Rambeau back to her
her normal form back to her human form
and then took off back to his Citadel
right looks like a giant note for
everybody like you know you're summoned
to the Tower of Doom at dusk tomorrow
you know and it's like okay you know
whatever but it's kind of cool because
pannier you jump to Colossus right
Colossus taking off to go see saasy he
basically approaches her in the middle
of the night gives her flowers you know
really kind of show some affection this
is kind of a big thing here in reality
I'm not 100% sure why this was a plot
point because if that was a case I guess
maybe Jim shooter was toying with the
idea of having Colossus leave Kitty
Pryde but it kind of seemed unnecessary
and just sort of out in the middle of
nowhere right and one of the things that
sort of chimed in a bye-bye Wolverine is
it's kind of the answer that Jim shooter
gives us is that the reality is this
seems to be some kind of side effect of
her healing her
poverty's right like she's been healing
Colossus and Colossus fell in love with
her that kind of seems to have been the
case and it's interesting because
Wolverine kind of offers his explanation
to night crawler like how does her race
interpret love right there from a whole
different rage through a whole different
culture when it comes to this character
of saasy it may be one of these things
where for her love is no different than
breathing or something along those lines
it's not really a relevant thing now the
fact that she shows affection the way
that she does shows that love really
seems to be something important but for
her love and friendship may very well be
the same thing right there really is no
differentiation there and so ultimately
what this means is that Colossus is
probably stuck in the friend zone good
luck getting off that ladder man and so
as a result of that and the various
heroes end up showing up to Doctor Doom
Citadel now this is hugely important and
the reason for this is because Doctor
Doom basically says neo tells these
various guys I've committed a bunch of
evil deeds in my time that I've been
here on Bower world and even before the
know before the point that I came to
battle room so we're going to rectify
this right we're going to fix this and
we're gonna work out basically gonna
take care of this
the first thing I'm gonna do is
reconstitute Kane the Conqueror who dr.
doom it incinerated before and then the
second thing is I'm gonna send him back
to his time and he's gonna go back to
his future from here I will give you
guys any wish that you ask right I'll
give you guys whatever it is that you
want and this is a really really cool
thing because what this does is it gives
the impression that Doctor Doom is being
somewhat benevolent but he's he's
basically a good guy now turn over a new
leaf but the heroes don't really trust
him and there's an important reason for
that and we'll get it'll get why here in
a second because it's not just the idea
that Doom has been a bad guy right they
could look at this and say with this
newfound power good and evil are
irrelevant to doom right it's just him
carrying out what he believes to be the
right thing they end up turning him down
by the end of saying we don't want to
have anything to do with with your power
or whatever and then dooms response is
fine then leave and if you guys come
back I'm gonna kill you right so with
Julia carpenter basically being missing
when the group neo comes back together
again
Captain America kind of sneaks back in
and ultimately ends up coming across the
path of doom right now doom doesn't kill
him we never really expected him to and
instead what you get here is a really
cool conversation right one of the
things that takes place is Ulysses
Clause tasked with tracking down Julia
carpenter for Captain America and then
when that happens Julia carpenter ends
up grabbing him and basically the energy
passes from her into him and then he
just kind of goes forward accordingly
showing back up to dr. doom himself of
course we'll find out what's going on
with that but there's this really cool
conversation we're doomed basically
explains what his plan is the great
Oh scheme behind why it is that he
attained or looked to attain the power
of the Beyonder in the first place the
intention of doom as has always been
with trying to trying to attain absolute
power both with this story the stories
before this is to travel to the realm of
Mephisto and free his mother's soul
that's always been the intention of doom
and so the results of that is a Captain
America in Doom find a bit of
camaraderie right they've both lost
something significant Captain America
losses past Doctor Doom lost his mom but
the difference is how they approach it
doomed talks about how he doesn't really
care about the goings-on of humanity and
and and really says like me ruling over
earth ruling over this universe in this
capacity it would be like you ruling
over a droplet of water with amoeba
inside right like of what use would it
be to you why would you care about what
that amoebas doing it's irrelevant to
you because this life-form is so much
lower than yours
that's how doom kind of perceives things
but notice this doom is still showing
some very human emotions meaning the
doom isn't that far from being human in
the first place right he's not really as
far removed from his humanity as he
would like to believe and so from there
you end up switching over to Colossus
making out with Ozzie so obviously he's
not the friendzone and then here comes
Charles Xavier blocking like Colossus
with his chick and then Xavier is like
Colossus in response like like literally
Colossus is like go away professor and
he's like no man I'm sorry dude I know
you're trying to get your groove on you
need to show up here this is an
emergency this is a very important thing
and so what this does is it goes into
why it is that the super heroes still
don't really trust doom despite his
claims that he's so far removed from
humanity Captain America asks do we
really believe that Doom is a good guy
do we really believe he's a he's a great
guy and then each hives in it says
remember what's the first thing Doctor
Doom did with his newfound power and the
response that Reed Richards is he fixed
his face and what that means is that
Doctor Doom is still wholly human
despite the vast amount of power they
has the first thing he did was worry
about himself that was the first thing
he did right a being that that is as
benevolent as doom claims to be right a
being this is far removed from humanity
and really wants to do good do right by
the world wouldn't focus on themselves
you don't really care about people if
you only ever focus on yourself right
that's the illusion of the narcissist
and so the result of this is that they
all really kind of chime in and say yes
at the end of the day we can't really
trust doom here so then they start
asking the question what do we do like
do we attack and and for the most part
all of them really kind of try Manning
and really kind of go alongside Captain
America
yeah let's attack the sky let's do this
guy and the only one who's really kind
of on the outside here is Colossus and
the response of Colossus is like but
what has he ever really done to us
though like sure he's a bad guy and he's
done some bad things but so is Magneto
magneto saw some pretty horrible things
we still have him on our team and at the
same time doom is basically said I will
give you guys things you know I will do
things to make your life better he may
never ever ever harm us and if that's
the case if we go and we attack him
first
despite the fact that he's actually done
nothing to us then yeah it's a
preemptive strike it's a just-in-case
like hate we're gonna we're gonna attack
you just in case you decide you want to
harm us the response of Captain America
is that may very well be right but
that's what we're doing in a unanimous
vote everybody has to vote yes if
anybody here votes no we do not attack
we do not strike and this is kind of an
important thing right because Captain
America is aware of the the stakes in
the situation he literally says it could
very well be that we get struck by a
bolt of lightning from the sky boom like
this is watching this whole thing go
down and if we all vote yes
we're dead right it'll it'll happen that
fast and ultimately Colossus says yeah
that may very well be the case but we
have to do that yes I say we fight and
at that moment a bolt of lightning comes
down from the sky and kills them all
every single superhero dies man actually
what if we were not doing a conclusion
if I wanted to extend this by one video
I would leave you on that cliff hey I'd
be like what I being said guys are gonna
bring this video to an end I think it'd
be pretty amazing like it'd be it'd be
pretty hilarious but of course it ends
up being doom who was the one who did
this and was actually watching it all go
down this is an important thing that
goes on here because ulysses klaw
watching all this take place is really
just kind of like did you really do it
did you kill them and dooms like yes I
really kind of had to now it's
interesting because one of the things
that dooms says is he has to keep that
power bottled up inside of him right if
he lets loose if he lets his guard down
if he shows a moment of vulnerability
then ultimately he'll lose all that
power it'll escape his body and who
knows what could happen the slightest
drop in concentration the slightest
lapse in focus could lead to the ruin of
the entire universe and in reality given
what we know about the Beyonder now the
entirety of the multiverse right it
could all come crashing down because the
doom lost focus because he fell asleep
or something along those lines it's a
huge weight to carry as the way you end
up doing is picking up with enchantress
and this is kind of important because
you sort of get into why they've
did what he did in the first place and
so you pick up with enchantress back in
in Marcia's apartment again kind of in
Denver floating out there in space and
she starts talking to one of the
elementals to a water elemental and it's
really just kind of like what have you
heard but what she basically says is
that like the Beyonder is this being
that exists out in some space called the
beyond verse the entire space that makes
up the universe for lack of a better
word that the Beyonder occupies viondra
was one in himself unto it right so it
was like if the universe had sentience
so think eternity from Marvel Comics and
that's what the Beyonder was he was
everything in that space and when when
he had essentially looked into the main
Marvel Universe that what he had seen is
that individual beings had desire and
they had desire because they were
unsatisfied it is our power that his I
have women that desired men that desired
money they desired no companionship that
is I had all manner of different things
but they had these desires because they
didn't have them right there's a thing
they want because they don't currently
have it and some emotional or biological
need drives them to want that thing and
so seeing individuals who were
essentially incomplete really intrigued
him but it was it made him curious about
the various characters in the main
Marvel Universe and so the idea of the
Beyonder is if desire is what drives
people then how far will they go to
achieve those desires how far will they
go for that and so that's why he
basically abducted the various heroes in
various villains and then brought them
all here and that's why he said slay
your enemies and all your desire will be
yours what are you willing to do what is
it that you're going to ask for that's
really kind of the big thing that was
what the Beyonder was sort of looking to
get into now ultimately this led to
Doctor Doom initiating his plan and then
entering into the realm of the Beyonder
using the power of Galactus and then in
turn stealing the power of the beyond
this is a very important thing because
the questions asked by inch hand wrist
is the Beyonder dead and the response to
the elemental is no the Beyonder is
still alive but it's hiding out it's
basically too weak to really affect
anything or to attack doom and so it's
basically just biding its time and
waiting for a moment when it can steal
its power back right so dooms statement
of destroying the Beyonder of killing
the Beyonder is false
the Beyonder has been defeated and its
powers been taken but at the moment it's
still very much alive as an entity
that's out there it's just vastly deep
Howard right it's much weaker than it
would normally be and so in this moment
of what appears to be vulnerability when
docked with Doctor Doom when he's
essentially falling asleep ulysses klaw
who's a current host of the beyonders
energy right that's what's been
happening
honors energy traveled envy Incredible
Hulk and then left the Incredible Hulk
went Julia carpenter and the travel from
Julia carpenter into ulysses klaw in
this moment of vulnerability
the Beyonder covers its power and it
seeks to take it back but Doctor Doom
immediately wakes up now he doesn't know
that ulysses klaw is currently the home
of the beyond right where the Beyonder
is residing in a subconscious uh he
simply just believed that you know
falling asleep that things could run
awry right now here's the interesting
thing about this this is what's so
intriguing is given this vast amount of
power technically speaking Doctor Doom
doesn't need to sleep right he could
sustain himself with infinite amount of
energy so he never really needs to sleep
the difference here and the reason why
this matters is because Doctor Doom has
not yet changed his body essentially
right like converted his body into a
like a pure form of energy because
doesn't really fully know how to
comprehend or even control these powers
right they're still brand new to him
with all the vast sorcery sorcerers
abilities at his disposal at the end of
the day it pales the comparison to the
power he has now and even the power he
had with Galactus this is an infinite
amount of power now something else that
I do want to kind of chime in here I
want to chime in with a difference
between what this shows us with the
Beyonder and what Jonathan Hickman did
Jonathan Hickman changed a lot of what
the Beyonder was when he did Avengers
and New Avengers at the time this story
was written at the time that Secret Wars
too happened that was basically it
like it was just too beyond and there
was really nothing more to it than that
now Secret Wars 3 in that Fantastic Four
story which changed some things and
we've got videos we got multiple videos
on on the molecule man 2 beyond or
different things like that so you know
I'll link those down in the description
or at least my editor will if you guys
want to see this or if you want to see
those but the overall gist is that at
the time this sword was written yes this
is the first time that the owners
introduced the Beyonder makes it all up
right now given what we've seen over the
years the way to beyond her actually
function is initially following this the
beyond verse was this space that was
Vasily was it was infinite in size right
he was it dwarfed the size of the
multiverse why the multiverse was like a
drop in the bucket in comparison to the
size of the beyond verse right it was
colossal but what we've seen over the
years is the introduction of the
beyonders right the idea that the
Beyonder was one was simply a member of
a singular race that was called to be
honors now that was introduced I believe
in the Secret Wars three Fantastic Four
story right the unofficial conclusion
that basically revealed that that the
Beyonder are the reason why he exists
here is because when Owen Reese
experienced his accident that basically
gave him his powers that he had
unwittingly opened up a portal
to be honest right and normally that's
how cosmic cubes are created right you
open up a portal to the beyond verse the
energy comes out and then it goes into
some kind of the stasis cube which is
known as the Cosmic Cube right the
overall gist is that in this part of the
beyonders energy had basically emanated
out into the universe and the other part
of the of the energy went into Owen
Reese right so essentially that changed
the origin that we got in this story but
the overall gist or the the idea behind
this was the Beyonder of course went
through all the steps that you're
basically seeing here the important
thing what hickman established is that
the Beyonder as you see him in that in
this moment is really more of like a
child and that's why while the beyonders
power is vastly infinite while it is
insane in scale it is in a lot of ways
dwarfed by the power of the other
beyonders right to be honors that we saw
in in Jonathan Hickman Avengers and New
Avengers the power is far more brand in
scope than the power that you're seeing
here that dr. doom is wielding but the
fact that dr. doom was able to wield the
power of the Beyonder in this story is
why it was that he became God king Doom
during a secret Wars that Jonathan
Hickman wrote in 2015 he was basically
retaining a power he was already
relatively familiar with even if it was
only more powerful than what he had
what are you experienced in this
particular story hopefully that makes
sense but it's kind of an important
little little caveat right what is up
happening is the question of a really
ulysses klaw kind of starts to
manipulate dr. doom right he basically
starts saying things like if this power
is if so grand then what about your
subconscious right what keeps your
subconscious from manifesting things you
know and starts to kind of put in this
idea of like well maybe the heroes are
actually alive right like maybe you
killed the heroes but if you really
wanted to kill them you would have
disintegrated them but you just blew
them up so maybe you didn't really want
them to die you know when doctors doom
kind of starts to question this it's
like well let me show you what's going
on out there
right you know the others cars like let
me show you what's most likely taking
place or something along those lines and
gives a hologram we're basically saasy
goes running over to where it is where
it is that Colossus and then we're out
where the explosion took place and then
finds kind of the tattered attire
remains of everyone the only person
she's really able to resurrect
is Colossus the issue is that it takes
the last of her life force in order to
do it and so of course saasy ends up
dying but in the aftermath of that
Colossus takes the body of Reed Richards
which is one of the only ones that could
survive the explosion because of his
elastic nature resurrects Reed Richards
and then following that Reed Richards
goes through and just starts using the
machinery the the medical machinery
which been essentially healed and
revived him and then starts basically
repairing and
all the other heroes and it's kind of a
funny thing here because Jim shooter
sort of messes with us because the idea
is that the the kind of conversation
that's going on here is where ulysses
klaw says this is a possible scenario
that's what's going on right now you at
the end of the day dooms like well if I
if I believe you then like I could will
that into fruition right I can
alternately resurrect those heroes not
really intending to but my subconscious
would do it because it would want them
to be alive but it's kind of toying with
these things you know is sort of ulysses
klaw manipulating in toying with dr.
doom you didn't actually want to kill
the heroes if you did want to kill the
heroes you would have atomized them
right that would have been it they would
have been destroyed and nothing more
would have come out of that is one of
these interesting moments because in
response to that we're dooms like no no
no they're dead right like I kill them
they are absolutely dead suddenly a
hammer comes flying in right like Thor's
hammer comes flying into the Citadel and
then doom momentarily loses control of
his powers and destroys a planet in the
in the process right and so he manages
to contain them back down again but in
the ulysses klaue reaches out it says
give me a portion of your power and I
can in turn go and defeat the hero so
that you can rest and you can
reconsolidate your powers back into
yourself and so what you end up getting
and this is one of the things that that
people are talking about when people say
like critics didn't really like the
story with this like you kind of see
this sort of cartoony element coming out
right and so far as like all these
massive monsters are basically spawned
by ulysses clock in an intern you know
they all end up facing off against the
heroes now for the most part Ultron is
is resurrected as well and Ultron is
basically made to face off against the
heroes but in the middle of the whole
thing
Ultron basically explodes right and then
here comes wasp seemingly out of nowhere
exiting the body of Ultron and basically
offers his explanation of you know she
had essentially gotten two Ultron's body
and she started yanking wires and made
Ultron explode so following that Captain
America takes out Ulysses Klaw and then
goes to confront Doctor Doom now here's
where things get hairy right in this
part of the story and here's where Jim
shooter doesn't really offer a
definitive explanation in terms of
what's going on and the reason for that
is that when Captain America gets in and
confronts Doctor Doom Doctor Doom
destroys Captain America right he
atomizes him well there's suddenly
Captain America pops back up again and
then dr. doom atomizes Captain America
and then Captain America keeps popping
back up right and ultimately gets the
upper hand on doom and then doom really
kind of starts to freak out as his power
goes awry now while all that's going on
ulysses klaw is watching the whole thing
unfold and the reason why this is
important is because Jim shooter can go
one of both ways here either it's
Ulysses Klaw with this fraction of the
beyonders
a fraction the power that he got from
Doctor Doom constantly resurrecting
Captain America bringing him back and
then really sort of kind of established
and there's this sort of vulnerability
in Doctor Doom the other alternative is
that his doctor dooms own subconscious
right he just he doesn't really want to
kill a Captain America but he is killing
Captain America so he just
subconsciously keeps resurrecting it
right it can go either way in this
particular discussion that's one reason
why if so it's so wild and that's why
it's kind of interesting because it's
not really there's not like a moment of
like ulysses klaw saying yes me
resurrecting Captain America and
ultimately resulting in Doctor Doom
losing confidence in himself is going
exactly as I had planned
it doesn't really work that way you
don't really see anything that on the
note and so in that moment because of
the fact that Doom is experiencing this
this moment of vulnerability this is the
moment where Ulysses Klaw strikes with
the Beyonder basically reaches into dr.
doom takes his power back and then then
that's basically it right he forces dr.
doom back into his current form
he sends dr. doom to the future right
because dr. doom had actually come from
the future at the time this story kicked
off I think it was Fantastic Four to 28
it's kind of where it picks back up
again but he is up getting yanked back
into the future ulysses Claus of course
out of the picture and essentially the
entire conflict is over right the
Beyonder has essentially vanished right
has basically disappeared and gone back
to whatever it is that he does which you
actually find out in secret Wars -
before the other superheroes at that
point it's the question of what do we do
next right it's all is really a little
bit of R&R it's everybody kind of kind
of collecting themselves giving
themselves back together again and it is
sort of like what's the next thing that
we do now what you also get is kind of a
cool explanation here in the sense that
you end up having Captain America
traveling off to the side you know when
there's a sort of speculation about
different things happening across the
planet but it wasn't really done by
Doctor Doom it wasn't really done by the
molecule man it just kind of seemed to
happen right Ben Graham for example
reverting back into his human form and
then going back into his stone form and
Reed Richards sort of surmises that
given the nature of the planet that
basically it's some kind of residual
energy that essentially grants the will
advance the wishes of various
individuals if their desire is strong
enough right if their will is strong
enough and that's how you kind of got
explanations of things like we need a
base of operations slowly there's a base
of operations there right we need food
suddenly there's food we need water
suddenly there's water different things
like that the planet basically manifests
things for them presumably because of
what the beyonders done or some aspect
of the honors energy permeating the
planet and so Captain America of course
reforms a shield but this matters this
little plot point this little idea of
the planet basically catering to the
desires of
those who occupy it is significant
because Reed Richards essentially uses a
teleporting device to send the various
heroes back to the the ships as they
arrived in and then in turn intends to
send the ships back to earth and then
take them wherever they need to go and
you know basically drop them off but the
reason why this is important is because
what is up happening is she-hulk
ends up traveling with the Fantastic
Four to move away from Susan storms
position and to replace Ben Grimm on the
team and the reason why is because Ben
Grimm is staying behind and the reason
for this is because Ben Grimm wants to
basically figure out how to control his
power Ben Grimm can kind of switch back
and forth but it's not necessarily a
hardline thing now the reality of this
is that this has been speculated for a
long time by Reed Richards that Ben
Grimm could always do this right he
always had the ability to alternate
between a stone and his human form but
for whatever reason simply wasn't able
to do it right either because of how he
viewed himself some kind of mental block
or something along those lines but never
really was able to achieve that ability
and so because of the fact that he can
alternate back and forth and because of
the fact that Ben wants to kind of
master and learn how to achieve this
what he basically ends up doing is
staying behind now this basically picks
up in the things solo series right the
things solo series actually started back
in 1983 and ran for 36 issues it ran for
a little while right but it basically
kind of continues on in that little bit
of a story and then ultimately he's kind
of resigned back to his own individual
to his own stone form and just really
can't seem to returning it right it's a
hallmark of his character this kinda way
he's always been and ultimately as I'm
going back to the Fantastic Four but
basically the story ends that way right
binge is kind of sitting on a rock by
himself and it's just kind of like let's
see where this journey takes me but yeah
I enjoyed this story right as is a
classic story right so most modern fans
won't really care but I always thought
it was kind of a cool story and
interesting one to cover but if you guys
are new here to come as explained make
sure you all hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]